este gran almacén se ha convertido en el
lugar de llegada de miles de personas
que vienen de la ciudad de mariupol
otras poblaciones del sur del país que
llegan hasta aquí hasta sap orilla en el
transcurso de la tarde hemos visto
llegar al menos 300 vehículos pero en la
mañana había muchísimos más y cuando
llegan aquí las personas que vienen
realmente cansadas entran y lo primero
que encuentran es esa estación donde les
dan ropa y es que hay que tener en
cuenta que muchísimos de ellos llevan
semanas viviendo en refugios
subterráneos han tenido que abandonar
sus casas prácticamente sin nada
solamente con algunos de sus documentos
así que cuando llegan a este lugar lo
primero que les dan es la primera
asistencia que necesitan para empezar
alimentos calientes muchos de ellos
llevan incluso días sin comer porque la
ciudad está desabastecida les dan
primeros auxilios y les ayudan a
solucionar donde quedarse los que tienen
familias nuestras ciudades y todavía les
da el tiempo siguen hacia el norte del
país o hasta el oeste y otros se quedan
aquí en colegios y otros lugares
habilitados para bañarse para y luego
ellos decidan su destino ellas creen que
tener en cuenta que ellos no solamente
están afectados físicamente sino
psicológicamente han sido semanas
extremadamente duras solamente cuando
venían en la carretera cayeron dos
morteros que los hizo detener la
caravana por un par de horas y también
nos cuentan que la ciudad está
prácticamente destruida solamente queda
levantada la parte más cercana al puerto
y cuando se les pregunta muchos dicen
que ellos no creen que mario poll vuelva
a ser la misma